okay thank you very much so welcome to
today's presentation on training
yourself to be more creative of design
thinking seminar again I'm bill Burnett
the executive director of the design
program and I want to walk you through
what I think are so the three easiest
ways to train yourself to be more
creative there's a one of the writers in
the creativity field for years and years
and years is a guy named Edward de Bono
and I love this expression you can't dig
a new hole by digging an old one deeper
and so what we're going to do is teach
you to dig some new holes and just like
thinking just to give you a little bit
of a background started here at Stanford
we've been teaching design in this
integrated program between the art and
engineering schools for about six well
for 50 years exactly this year in 1963
was the first time the board of trustees
at Stanford granted us permission to
give out a degree which was a joint
degree between engineering and art and
so we've been exploring this
multidisciplinary field for quite a long
time and one of the graduates of this
program and one of our sort of um you
know famous guys is David Kelly he's
both the founder of IDEO probably the
world's you know for most innovation
consulting firm and the professor here
at Stanford where he also founded our
new Design Institute well new it's now
five years five years six years old the
d.school
and if you have an opportunity go check
out David's TED talk on creative
confidence the link is there but if you
just google David Kelly TED talk you'll
get his talk on creative confidence and
he's you know a just code as things as
I'm thinking is all about unlocking
potential and created creating creative
confidence in our students and one of
our ideas is that creativity is just
thought about it typically innate in
people but it has been poorly poorly
realized or poorly trained
and we've been working for the last 50
years here at Stanford and certainly for
the last six in the d.school with this
idea about design thinking to reenable
people's creativity so we you notice I'm
thinking is both the process and a
mindset it's a way of approaching
problem-solving but like everybody we
have a process diagram I wouldn't get
too hung up on it other than you know
kind of starts with a couple of
interesting ideas one is that we don't
start our design process with
specifications or research or things
like that we start our design process
with empathy empathy for the users we're
designing for this is different than
traditional forms of market research or
things this involves using the tools of
anthropology and ethnography to study
users in their activities to understand
what they're really up against in terms
of problem-solving so that we to find
the problem we do lots and lots of
techniques around coming up with lots of
ideas ideation and we believe that
because the problems were working on are
so difficult they can't really be solved
in a traditional way we build lots and
lots of prototypes and test things with
users it's really a co-creation process
in some ways and I'm going to be
focusing mostly on the id8 bubble here
but I wanted to just give you a
background in the overall process before
we get into the ideas of how to make
yourself more creative the again to sort
of just quickly brief on design thinking
it's a very dynamic approach to problem
solving and it works best on problems
that are called poorly bounded problems
or problems where you really can't get a
lot of data things about you know the
future the automobile or the future of
the computer or the or the the
smartphone there's no way to really look
into the future and get data so you need
to use other techniques we talked about
ourselves not solving problems or making
decisions but rather building our way
forward
so we use prototyping to for rapid
learning and improve
and and we use lots and lots of
different ways to solve problems because
we believe if you're choosing from a
small set of solutions you'll choose
poorly but if you choose from a large
set which is what we're going to be
talking about in terms of your personal
creativity you have a better chance of
having a good outcome actually we want
to talk that much about the empathy
phase but that's really what unlocks
innovation in some ways more than
anything else in our process because
because I'm thinking is really not only
approach to problem solving it's an
approach to problem finding most of the
time people are working on the wrong
problem in our experience and so we find
that the highest leverage and innovation
has sort of been reframing
what the problem is actually about and
that's where we use our empathic
observations and ethnography techniques
and prototyping techniques to provoke a
real understanding of the latent needs
involved in whatever problem we're
working on and then you know we think
it's a it's a pretty pretty much a new
perspective on how you create value
either for yourself or in an
organization it's this co-creation
process focused on real user needs and
and it's a very human centered process
so typically the solutions that come out
of it are not only innovative but pretty
action driven or action in the world's
room so as I said that's an overview of
design thinking but today I really want
to focus on this idea bubble or hexagon
I guess in this case and aviation covers
all of the techniques we use to have
lots and lots and lots of ideas because
again there's a lot of evidence that
says if you choose from your first idea
or your second idea just a few ideas
you're typically choosing in a very
small and very confined problem space
but if you step back and brainstorm I be
a mind map do morphological analysis do
improv do lots of other techniques that
we teach you're going to generate a very
rich field of potential solutions and
from there you will choose potentially
better and more innovative sources
so how do we become great ideator x' or
in another way of looking at it is like
why is this even a problem what is this
whole thing about creativity we people
talk a lot about creativity and
innovation they talk a lot about you
know so the lack of of new ideas and
this is a business world today and
certainly as the environment changes and
the external circumstances changes
either for yourself or the organizations
you work in people are being asked to
come up with new solutions and be
creative which is kind of like your cat
coach saying run faster how the heck do
you do that right so what is this
creativity problem anyway you know the
ability to transcend traditional ideas
and create meaningful new ideas is one
definition so I'd like to just dive into
this a little bit but before we do that
I want to take a quick poll here's a
slide and then my question to you is
were you more creative as a child then
let's say you are today however however
you want to judge creativity whatever it
means to you were you more creative as a
child than you are today okay looks like
we're sort of stabilized here with about
270 people voting you want to close the
poll it looks like about half of you 49%
of you say yeah I was much more creative
as a child 24 25 percent of you say yeah
it was a little bit more creative when I
was a kid so 75 percent of you are
thinking maybe today something isn't
quite as good as it used to be when
you're five or six or seven or whenever
you decided you were a child and about
24 25 percent of you're saying now I
think today I'm more creative it'd be
interesting to dive into what that means
for people but I think in general when
I've done this poll and lots of
different seminars and lots of different
workshops it breaks down about the same
way but you know 78% of people say yeah
you know I feel like something is
missing in me today that I had as a kid
when I was a child of five or six or
seven and I was playing I could invent
magical worlds I could have you know a
rock could be a truck and that stick
could be a you know sword and I could
invent almost any sort of solutions to
any problems that I had and I would
argue that that is really kind of the
pure creativity that we're where many of
us are born with and then something
happens and mostly what happens is our
education system which promotes a
massive fear of failure and the search
for only one right idea and and then
there's always if you listen to David
Kelley's talk he talks about a friend of
he has grown up in Ohio who was and they
were in art class and you know first or
second grade and they were making stuff
out of clay and he made a horse and the
girl next to him said that doesn't look
like a horse that's a horrible horse and
of course his creativity at that point
was crushed because because what he felt
you know was a beautiful thing had been
judged to be not art so probably many of
us had that experience where somebody
told us hey you're not creative or
you're not an artist or you can't write
or you can't sing whatever it was and
you know that kind of put that first
ding in our creative confidence and then
a series of educational experiences
where our creativity curiosity whatever
was scrunched a bit when we tried to do
something outside the box or outside of
the command and control system that is
experience most of us had with education
but other than a social experience we've
had I want to dive a little deeper into
what is actually going on in our brain
around this creativity thing and one
tradition to a new field called neural
Darwinism now I'm going to talk a little
bit about neuroscience and what we know
about the brain and I want to first
preface that by saying that in when I
was going to school we talked about left
brain and right brain some of you
probably have written remember the book
drawing on the right side of the brain
and there's all these books about right
side of the brain robert Ornstein the
professor here at Stanford who
originally did that research you know
has since
in the book talking about how frustrated
he is that everybody misunderstood his
research about left and right brains but
I think that was a useful it was it was
an incorrect model as we now know from
more brain research but it was useful
because it did sort of break down a way
of thinking about two modes that we
operate in a creative mode and an
analytic mode we have new brain research
and I will argue that is probably
incorrect as well but useful and one of
them are interesting and useful ideas is
this notion that the brain like all the
other parts of our body was subject to
evolutionary pressures it's not just the
the intact animal that has to evolve in
the world it's all the parts of the
animal including our brain in our case
that evolved and in this case it evolves
through resource competition to process
information at the lowest possible
energy state now there's a picture here
of our brain in a 40 watt light bulb
the brain operates somewhere between 20
and 60 watts depending on what you're
doing but it's an average we think from
the research that we have the brain
operates in about 40 watts of continuous
output power so what's interesting about
that is my laptop I'm doing this
presentation on has got an 80 watt you
know processor the the Watson computer
that won jeopardy friends at about three
hundred and sixty thousand watts and and
and none of them these computers can't
fall in love they can't write a poem
they can't you know become a president
or create a company they're really
rather limited in what they can do they
can do you know wrote calculations very
very much more quickly than the human
brain but the human brain is really an
amazing processor and yet it had to
because it was computing for resources
with the rest of the body it can't take
all the energy you know you consume a
couple thousand calories you know a day
typically and a substantial portion of
that goes to running your brain because
your brain such a critical organ in the
function of a human being but 40 watts
think about it that's that's nothing so
how the heck did did the brain evolve
structures so that it could work at such
low and efficient energies well this is
some work from Dan Goleman and Don
Norman and a book called the psychology
of self-deception Dan Goleman you might
recognize the name he's the guy who
wrote the book on emotional intelligence
and he and Don Werner cognitive psych
guys and they've been studying the brain
by doing a bunch of different exercises
kind of teased out of basic I'd call it
a block diagram of how the brain works
so we think we have stimulus we have our
you know our five senses and things come
into our psyche they're hearing smell
touch taste and we think we kind of you
know just respond to what we see and
what we hear but it turns out it's
really not bad at all because the the
input bandwidth of the sensors is a
flood of information that if we were
processing all of it all the time the
brain would have to be you know 10 or 20
times more power hungry than it is so
really what happens if that stuff gets
sort of quickly censored and filtered
there's a lot more intelligence in your
body than just the brain
lots of things are pre processed on the
optic nerve path before it ever gets to
the brain for image recognition lots of
things are pre processed in your sense
of touch as well so that you can if you
think about how gymnasts and athletes
and other people can move with what they
call muscle memory it's actually a
combination of muscles and nerves
registering the position of their body
and space and then it reacts without a
direct processing by the brain but for
the stuff that we're we're talking about
you know today having good ideas and
being creative what happens is you see
all this stuff it gets censored and
filtered a little bit and gets thrown up
into the unconscious part of your brain
I'm just going to say the part that is
you're not you're not verbally aware of
you don't have any consciousness
and it's sorted by what psychologists
called schemas so the schema is you have
a schema for everything in schema for
chair you have a schema for shoe
whisking for dog is schema for man and
actually there's a schema for faces and
then there's a there's a neural path
that that encodes the face of a friend
or the face of your wife and after the
first few times you see something it
takes quite a bit of processing time to
recognize it but after a while and not
too long you've evolved very very short
very very rapid neural paths that encode
the information about these things so
these thousands and thousands maybe
millions of schemas that are in your
unconscious brain and then what happens
is in this little section called pre
consciousness there's a little
prediction engine that runs and it loads
up the schemas that it thinks you're
going to need and then consciousness
turns out to be really aware of about
one one hundred thousandth of the
processing that's going on in your brain
this is not that your brain is in such
that you only use 1/10 of your brain use
all of your brain all of the time
but what you can bring into
consciousness which are aware of through
through verbal and conscious activity is
really a tiny tiny fraction and that's
it to enable the brain to work at a very
very low energy level I'll give you an
example of a schema so here's a schema
that sort of a was a cultural schema if
you will
Mandira it was considered impossible for
a human being to run a four-minute mile
and many doctors psychologists
physiologist said this is not possible
humans can't run that fast and there was
even a claim that if they ran that fast
they would be able to breathe because
the air would be moving so quickly and
of course none of that turned out to be
true 25-year old Roger Bannister who was
an English medical student who trained a
couple days a week ran the first
four-minute mile run under four minutes
on may 6 1954 so the schema prior to
Rogers four-minute mile was this is
impossible and runners constantly came
up against this barrier and were
defeated
for whatever reason register was a Roger
was able to unleash that scheme and not
not not be governed by that he went
beyond that
in the first four-minute mile then of
course as soon as that it happened that
a schema was Oh a four-minute mile can
be run by a human it is possible sixteen
runners ran in the next 18 months and
now well over a thousand runners have
run better than this in fact I have a
student on the track team here who
regularly clocks 358 as his time and
he's not even you know top ten in c2a
anymore so one of the things I think I
want to start thinking about is how are
you chunking or schema tizen information
because what happens with these schemas
is what the psychologists say is we
don't really see what we're looking at
we only see what we're looking for and
so one of the things that happens to
folks when they get in a rat or they not
train their creativity is they're stuck
in schematic thinking where they're
really only seeing solutions that
they're looking for now the interesting
solution to that is to just change the
way you use image size information we'll
talk about how you do that in a second
the other thing that's really kind of
startling is to consciousness this thing
that we're aware of only one hundred one
hundred thousandth of all the
information it's actually being
processed consciousness turns out to be
only three hundred milliseconds lon
the way we know this unfortunately is
that there are people who have had
different parts of their brain damaged
by tumors or seizures or other things
and what we know now is that the brain
is organized you know it's a short
there's consciousness short-term memory
and long-term memory there have been
people who have had a tumor or something
and have no long-term memory so they we
know that short-term memory is roughly
seven to ten minutes long if anyone ever
saw the movie memento that was main
character had no long-term memory only
had a ten seven to ten minute memory
buffer and so after every ten minutes he
didn't know who he was talking to
anymore he had to start the conversation
again
but unfortunately there was a seventh
been several patients one well-studied
who had no sure had neither short-term
nor long-term memory and they live in
kind of a very difficult space of about
300 about a half a less than half a
second of ability to sort of grasp and
store what they see and are aware of and
so we know from those those studies the
consciousness is really only 300
milliseconds long so where's this going
well
alright so consciousness is 300
milliseconds long we all have good
short-term and long-term memory although
my short-term memory is sliding a bit as
I get older but given that we've got
this scheme where we grasp the
information in the world in our
conscious thinking in 300 milliseconds
throw it into short-term memory and if
it's important and it needs to be
encoded then becomes part of our
long-term memory what it tells us is
that really what we're doing is we're
creating a movies frame by frame of what
we see and the way we put the movie
together is our schemas we have a pre of
consciousness you know buffer in our
brain that's taking all the things that
that are possible and making predictions
about what will come next and that's how
we tie together a consistent image of
our existence so our consciousness is
300 milliseconds or short-term memories
seven minutes or long-term memory goes
forever as far as we know and that's how
we construct our reality it's not an
objective reality and sense that the
reality is actually there it's just the
reality we choose to perceive that a
good friend who says if you don't like
reality just change your mind but
anything that's fundamental way that's
sort of true now you know I'm going a
little deeper on this you know because I
just want to make sure we've got a
framework the other findings on
creativity and there we have some
measurements where you have certain
psychometric tools that you can measure
people and you can kind of say well
these folks over here gave more creative
responses than these these folks here so
if you measure high creatives and you
then put them in a brain scanner and you
get some different tasks to do we
rediscover three things that are
statistically significant about them one
they practically perceive the world
differently when you show them pictures
of
things different parts of their visual
cortex light up than other people they
see things more richly or they see
things more more precisely but they see
things differently and they actually
have a higher tech tactile response
which is interesting we don't understand
why this is true but they're just more
sensitive to the world in some way they
also have a high social awareness
response which is this empathy thing
many creative people are quite
introverted so I'm not saying that
they're social they just observe and
most introverts in fact observe the
world very carefully because they want
to keep the world at a distance and they
don't want to interact with it so they
become very good observers at high
empathy for the people in the world and
so you know you could teach yourself to
be a little more visually aware and more
tactically aware it's just do
sensitivity training you could train
your empathy to be more not more deep
for other people and for other
conditions but the one that's really
interesting because it reveals that
creativity is not something extra you
have it's actually a deficit people with
high creative with measure highly
creative on psychometric tools have a
low fear response to novelty when you
show them pictures of things they've
never seen before they should react with
a fear response or their amygdala should
light up a little cortisone cortisol
should flow adrenaline should flow this
makes sense that evolution would have
you know we're walking through the
jungle and something pops out you've
never seen before you should respond
with with a reaction to back away
interestingly high creative people have
a low or no fear response analogy well
the most interesting thing about that is
this is totally learn about in David
Kelly's talk he talks about a
psychologist a very famous psychologist
here at Stanford who's still teaching
Albert bandura he's well into his 80s
he's the person who studied phobias and
developed a very simple desensitization
technique to teach people to get over
their phobias and within a very short
period of time you know if you're
terrified of snakes or spiders he can
have you holding snakes and letting
spiders crawl in your arm it's a
completely learn a bolt rate to low your
lower your fear response to novelty by
the way the of
our word for this deficit it's called
creativity I mean and curiosity people
who don't who see something unusual and
instead of going what's that go ah
what's that you know it's the yes hand
response we find an improv that's so
liberating so a low fear response to
novelty can easily be learned and I
think if you look back to the very first
question I asked you why were you more
creative as a child when you were a
child you did not fear you didn't know
therefore you did not fear judgments
about your ideas criticisms about their
behaviors you were more open and more
free because you had were still kind of
undone damaged by the social and and
educational pressures that would come
later and so you were truly curious it
also turns out that evolution doesn't
like a lot of curious people a lot of
low fear response to novelty people it
would be evolutionarily advantageous if
a tribe or an organization of humans
thought the same way believed the same
things and followed the same patterns
and so if you have a tribe of folks and
they always hunt for the Buffalo out on
the plains and the Buffalo are always
there you don't want people you know
disturbing that that would be not
evolutionarily advantageous until of
course the climate changes or the
situation changes and then there's no
more buffalos out on the plains and
there's and you go in here and there's
no puffle oh so the tribe gets together
and does the rituals and shakes the
beads and the next year they're still no
Buffalo and the next year they're still
no Buffalo it would be at that point
highly advantageous to have one of those
crazy people in the tribe go hey you
know when you guys go over there looking
for Buffalo I go over here to this other
place and there's a ton of wildebeests
and you know I eat one it was pretty
good anybody want to go over here with
me so you need people who are highly
creative and we think you know in terms
of this deficit this brain deficit it's
only maybe five to ten percent of the
population evolved this way but they
would be useful
if you're trying to do oh say something
different and so then the good news is
creativity is not something you're born
with it's actually something you're born
without but that thing the deficit can
easily be trained so let's talk about
you know how would you know we're in a
box it's just true our brain schema ties
things in order to run it low very low
energy levels we we have to be this way
because evolution created us this way it
is the most efficient processor that we
know of in the universe to create
intelligence but it does work a very
specific way which is sort of the
opposite of the way we want to work when
we're trying to be creative so here are
the big ideas or that I call the
liberating ideas the box is real so that
so don't worry about it there's
absolutely nothing wrong with you have a
healthy brain it's working very
efficiently 20 or 30 or 40 watts and is
getting you through the day by ignoring
101 100 thousands of the evidence you
know and then the processing that's
actually going on and just giving you
the things you need to know and need to
see when you need them so creativity is
probably a brain deficit not a brain
special thing which is I think a big yay
and fantastic and you know we can all
learn to be less smart less less fearful
that's easy and that creativity is
actually a very high energy brain
behavior when we put people in standards
and we give them hard problems to solve
and they have these little moments of
you know revelation or we call them aha
moments their whole brain lights up
literally their whole brain lights up
and it popped powers up to a very very
high energy level which you couldn't
sustain for very long I don't know if
you I don't know about you but after you
know a lot of creative work or
brainstorming sessions or strategy
sessions you know my brain is a little
tired and it gets kind of numb so it's a
it's it's true that it's a high energy
brain behavior it's not normal but it
can be learned
and you can train yourself by lowering
your feel of fear of failure learning to
utilize schemas not against you but for
you manipulating scheme is in order to
trick your brain into creative could
behaviors and you can also access your
improvisational and other intelligences
in ways that I'm going to talk about
right now okay and not enough with
enough of the sort of deep brain stuff
back to this ideation I'm going to give
you three things you can do that I think
are pretty actionable a little bit maybe
contrary to you know common sense in
some ways but very actionable and things
that you can do to train yourself to be
more creative number one I want you to
train yourself to get stuck now this
sounds a little weird but let me explain
it to you there's a great book on
personal creativity I still use it it
was started written back in the 70s but
it's been updated a bunch of times
james adams who's a professor emeritus
here at stanford now real book called
conceptual blockbusting a guide to
better ideas highly recommend Jim's book
it's fantastic but it's full of
exercises and and theory and very
practical things that you can do it's
very good for personal creativity and he
has an exercise in there that I've run
thousands of times all over the world
it's called the 30 circles exercise and
you can do the same exercise with a
paperclip for any any objects it's
basically take take something common
like a circle and make it into something
and and then you demand a high number of
ideas 100 ideas for a paperclip you know
30 30 and different things you can do
with a circle it's a great exercise
because it's so simple you can run it
with a piece of paper and a pen and a
willing audience and everybody gets
stuck they run out of ideas in the first
15 secondary 20 seconds and they do that
because I kind of trick them and I do
some other things to put them in the box
and so what I like about it is it
creates this getting stuck feeling and
what most of us do when we get stuck is
we don't actually stay if we don't
identify the feeling we don't really
don't like it because it feels like
failure and so our fear and failure you
know filters start operating and then we
immediately want to do something else
instead of staying in the stuck place we
want to go to our email or we want to
you know do the budgets or something you
know anything looks better than stuck
but almost everybody has a moment where
they go well let's see baseball I can go
to the baseball I could a soccer ball it
could make it something else and those
are all things you could do inside the
circle and then they go hey wait a
minute I could make it a daisy I could
make it a sunflower I could make you and
they we have what we call an aha moment
and that moment you know that the I'm
totally stuck and oh wow I have a whole
bunch of new ideas that little moment I
don't know how many milliseconds it
takes across that barrier but something
happens and their brain goes from no
activity to tons of activity I'm sure if
we put them in a scanner it would light
up like a Christmas tree and there's a
burst of endorphins and there's a burst
of dopamine and your brain feels good
and you like that feeling so I want you
to train yourself to get stuck and be
aware of what where it feels where you
feel stuck in your body because if you
you know I was once doing a workshop
with a bunch of financial services
people and his Rabanne course and the
banker came up to me at lunch at lunch
but he said you know I did it exercise I
just got stuck and I gave up I'm not
creative I gets I just get stuck and I
said well you don't understand I get
stuck hundreds of times a day I'm always
doing things I don't know how to do
that's the nature of design it's not
about getting stuck it's about what you
do with it and actually being stuck is a
gift because I know from experience that
right on the other side of stuck that
hundred milliseconds later is my aha
moment and so you want to challenge
yourself with problems you don't know
how to solve and you want to stay you
don't want to stay stuck too long
because it is actually a very
uncomfortable feeling but you want to be
you want to challenge yourself to get to
that stuck
place and then see if you can release
yourself but because the stuck is the
schema you're working with right now no
longer has any ideas left in it when you
run out of all the things to do with a
circle that's inside the circle there's
just no more things I don't know any
more answers after I do all the
baseballs and basketballs everything
else smiley faces sad faces but once I
get to the outside the circle schema
flowers sunshine buh buh buh then and
then two circles can be eyeglasses
wheels on the bus with a block and you
just keep going and going and going and
when once you know that you can
manipulate the schemas and that stuck is
actually your friend it's the ones it's
it's the feeling in your brain that's
saying there's no more ideas here go
look somewhere else then you get
released then you have that aha moment
and I'll tell you I think designers are
just junkies for that moment where they
have a good idea because it does release
really happy chemicals in your brain and
and we actually seek being stuck so
train yourself to find that moment and
then and then stay there in it and
understand that stuck is just one short
millisecond away from that aha number
two everybody brainstorms most people I
watched brainstorm brainstorm very
poorly I want you to train yourself to
brainstorm well this is the most used
and most abused tool I see in personal
creativity and group creativity people
say they're brainstorming but when I
watch them doing it I have no idea what
it is but it ain't agreeing sir not the
way I frame it anyway and when you
brainstorm here's the here's the reframe
for you here's the defined part of our
model where we read to find the problem
I don't want you to think about
brainstorming having ideas I want you to
think about jazz which think about
making beautiful music when a jazz
ensemble gets together it's not about
doing the same thing that done before
it's about doing something completely
different so you wouldn't expect to sit
in with Miles Davis in the Miles Davis
xx tad on the kind of blue album which
is the sort of best-selling album of all
time in jazz it was the breakthrough
album for miles with the most amazing of
John Coltrane Cannonball Adderley bill
Levin
Jimmy Cobb Paul Chambers you wouldn't
sit in with them and say I'm going to
play jazz with you guys if it was the
first time you'd ever picked up a
saxophone or even you know you'd only
had you know 10 or 20 hours of lessons
on a saxophone because to play jazz at
that level requires and it makes amazing
amount of skill well it's the same thing
with brainstorming you don't just show
up and say oh I know how to do this here
here's my saxophone I'll play music with
you guys you have to practice and the
mechanics of brainstorming are
surprisingly difficult and even after
you get the mechanics right even if you
play scales on your saxophone that
doesn't mean you can play jazz
brainstorming is a complex interaction
of conscious and unconscious effects
that occur verbally and non-verbally
between people who are truly engaged in
the moment of trying to make something
that they've never made before and it's
partly this 10,000 hour problem you know
there's this theory that it takes 10,000
hours to get to mastery at anything well
it takes about a thousand hours to move
from competent to expert and it takes at
least a hundred hours to move from
novice to competent so although
everybody thinks they know how to jab a
brainstorm this mastering the art of
like being right in the moment and
having ideas one after the other and
having unique and exciting ideas and
going wide and going crazy just
inventing in the moment how many of you
have actually practiced a hundred hours
on your instrument of your brain to
trigger schematic free thinking to
trigger the ability to move quickly and
frictionlessly between I did idea to
work off of the other person's offering
somebody says let's do this and you say
let's do that somebody says let's do
this and you immediately have the next
the next idea this kind of competency
and what I call Burke you know jazz
thinking or brainstorming thinking is
something you have to work hard at I was
taught brainstorming by the guy who
invented our program back in 1976 I
added up the hours I'm at about 95
500 hours in spittle and that's and
that's it's got to be you know just
getting a saxophone and making sounds is
not practicing right you have to
actually do this well in fact it's worse
to just practice brainstorming poorly so
you want to want to do it well and
actually have I had the opportunity to
be studied in a brain study on brain
storming and I've almost gotten to
frictionless brain
not quite I still make a lot of mistakes
because this is a mind-body problem
right this is how do you get your brain
out of its own way how do you integrate
all of your intelligence emotional
intelligence physical intelligence
kinesthetic intelligence the facts and
figures that you know and really create
something new and in the moment and it
there's two things I want to teach you
about brainstorming that will make your
brainstorming much better when you come
into a brainstorming session you're
typically coming from your analytic side
you just came from the budget meeting or
you're doing schedules of you're doing
emails or something and now you need to
move to your synthesis side you need to
have a moment where you calm down and
get present with the problem that you're
going to solve and this is a this is
prompted by warming up what I see all
that then we would an athlete's run a
mile without stretching first no you
pull a muscle
I see people jumping into brain storms
as if you know they couldn't pull a
conceptual muscle they don't warm up
I'll give you a fantastic we use all of
we steal a lot from improv we had a
wonderful professor here at Stanford
named patrician Ryan who wrote who
taught improv for 30 years here her
protege Dan Klein is now teaching it and
we used an all the time in our workshops
to help people
brainstorm better and he warms it up by
using a lot of games from the improv
world right improvisation much like
brainstorming have to be ready in the
moment to create there's always an
offering from your partner and there's
always a yes and and we use a game
called sound ball where you throw an
imaginary ball around she's making sound
sounds we use a game called proverbs
where people just say random words in a
sentence and eventually wisdom emerges
there's another wonderful game that
dance taught is called remember that
time when where you just Vanessa that's
the lead you just say remember that time
when we went fishing and then the next
person says yeah and we caught this
giant salmon and again it was funny
because we weren't it wasn't in salt
water yeah and this is a weirdest salmon
I ever saw it was purple he's purple Sam
you they just keep going these these
games teach you to start the free
association process they relaxed the
analytic side of your brain and with the
synthesis and the verbal playful side of
your brain warm up and emerge and it
creates much better brainstorming
sessions Elizabeth Gerber who's a former
master student of mine and she went on
to get a PhD studied this she's now at
Northwestern University she's the person
who started the design for America
program she's really quite an
accomplished young academic and she's
put up a site because she studied improv
and brainstorming as part of her
research the sites www better brainstorm
calm it's full of these tools I would
highly if you do nothing else go to that
site learn one or two ways to warm your
team's up warm yourself up before you
before you start and you'll have much
better outcomes the other thing that we
find is that people typically after
they've done a big brainstorm they
either don't sort their ideas or they
sort them poorly they sort them by
what's feasible look like what we
actually do which gets you back to the
first three ideas you've ever had we
suggest sorting instead by potential
because we believe the potential can
always you can always develop
feasibility out of high potential ideas
and we have a bunch of different ways of
sorting ideas but I think you just want
to be mindful of selecting differently
so if in the beginning you warm up
better you'll have a good brainstorm and
then if you select your ideas
differently rather than less sorting for
potential rather than what's doable
you'll prompt yourself to think more
creatively about the possibilities so
brainstorming will in fact transform you
as a creative person the data shows that
novices with poor setup and poor
follow-through poor warm-up and poor
sorting get bad results
but you have to be good enough at your
instrument your brain to create in the
moment so you've got to get at least 100
hours of really focused brainstorming
and we suggest the you know the ways to
improve your brainstorming output is to
warm up with improv games and select
ideas for potentials and then finally
space not this kind of space but the
kind of space you work in we have a very
very strong with very strong correlation
around the d.school we've completely
rebuilt our teaching spaces we designed
our own spaces are unlike anything at
the university and they're some of the
most engaged in attractive spaces and
everybody wants to use them because they
don't look like this space creates
behavior you've all been probably
students at some time when you walk into
a room and all the seats are bolted to
the floor and they're facing a
chalkboard with a little stage you know
what's going to happen you're going to
come in sit down you're going to be
lectured at it's time to turn off your
brain and open up your laptop for my
students do you open up your laptop get
on Facebook open to chat windows you
know get on Google Google Hangouts and
ignore whatever's going on on stage so
this kind of behavior is prompted by the
physical space and it's not a very
creative behavior here's what the spaces
look like in you know in addy school
teaching from there is no front there is
no back there are lots of white boards
there's post-its all over the place all
the furnitures on wheels the room can be
completely reconfigured on the fly
depending on what the activities are and
when the student has never been in a
preschool classroom before enters this
space they have no idea what behaviors
are expected other than it's not going
to be like other classrooms they've been
in and you know we see over and over
again the impact that space has on your
your state of mind there is a big
Harvard study that was done about space
36,000 scientific pay group of papers
that were ranked as highly innovative
and one of the outcomes of that was
there's a building building at MIT where
all the good research was done so it's
just this crappy old warehouse didn't
nobody was supposed to use but it got me
positioned as lab spaces and it was a
very Ron modifiable environment and that
seemed to have a significant impact on
the output of the researchers so we
would suggest you create some kind of a
war room in your own home or some kind
of place a place even a corner of a room
where is is your creative space and
would put stuff up on the walls put
pictures that make information about the
problems you're working on or the ideas
that you're having persistent I think
this is what Pinterest is actually is
all about Pinterest is like creating a
virtual creative space on the net for
your for your thinking
remove all status clues in our in our in
our environment we remove the stage on
stage effect of the professor at the
front of the room we any kind of status
stuff defeats creativity make the make
your space self authoring so that it can
automatically morph into the space you
need it to be for a creative act so if
you're building something or you're
modeling something or you're drawing or
you're writing or you're thinking the
space should should reflect your state
of mind not the other way around
two good references on this The New
Yorker article it talks about the
information about mi t--'s raw space and
no space seems to change the behavior of
researchers and a book two guys at the
d.school wrote called making space about
creating the creative spaces might be
useful as you think about changing that
so my takeaways real quickly a member
who have a couple minutes for questions
changing yourself is really all about
changing your behavior so it's not about
changing what's going on in your brain
does have very little control over for
that but you can't change the way you
behave three powerful methods to make
yourself more creative would be to get
stuck more often move to a jazz
brainstorming model and create a space
somewhere in your home or wherever you
work that demands these new behaviors
and you know model the behavior you want
if you act differently you will think
differently and reward yourself for
being different if nobody else will make
sure you
yourself rewards for acting in a
different way by the way it takes about
eight weeks to establish a new habits
say the at least eight weeks for me much
longer sometimes but the cognitive psych
guys say it takes about eight weeks to
ingrain a new behavior so you need to
behave this way for about eight weeks
before you start to feel this way and
I'll leave you with the gun decode be
the change you want to see in the world
which in addition to global talks about
what you have to do inside to be the
kind of person you want so if you want
to be more creative get stuck more often
brainstorm better and find yours carve
out a space in the world where your
creativity is nurtured one question is
so what do you what do you thoughts on
websites like Lumosity which uses games
to exercise the brain actually I have to
my senior students doing their senior
project with Lumosity they're inventing
a new methodology for brain training
that involves music and rhythm I think
there is actually quite a bit of
evidence in there and they're gathering
quite a bit were they run a 30 or some
forty million users playing these
different games to exercise the brain I
you know my guess is um so I would think
that they're valuable I think they're
great certainly has warm-up exercises
for creativity I think some of those
exercises are designed around exercising
you know choice and rational thought so
they push you more into the analytic
side than the than the creative side of
your thinking but in general I think
it's probably pretty valuable stuff and
I think if I don't know if it's if it
keeps your brain more nimble longer but
I don't think there's any way it could
hurt another question the fender-benders
research was specifically about reducing
fears to reducing phobias and they had
very specific outcomes in fear of
spiders fear of snakes fear of flying
and is there is it possible to overcome
the generalized field
failure you know I think I think it is
but I don't think you'd do it that way
for instance when we do brainstorming
that one rule that really matters is no
crit no critique right and the reason
you do the no critique rule that
everybody has to accept every idea
that's put out there no matter how crazy
even if it's off-topic whatever is in
order to create a safe place where you
can learn to freely exercise your
creativity without worrying about being
criticized but what really happens in
brainstorming is that your self
criticize you you fail to to flush out
an interesting possible solution because
you've already edited it in your pre
consciousness and so you're not aware of
that solution so when you practice I
think you think you lower fear or
failure by doing very specific practices
in the case of brainstorming you not
only create an environment where you're
not criticizing others you're learning
to not self criticize ideas because the
true fear of failure is inside it's not
it's not really in the group probably
most people have a hard enough shell at
this point that it's not somebody you
know criticizes an idea they can keep
having it but it's more about the
internal critic that's running almost
unconsciously so the more you practice
brainstorming the more and you do it
well and you learn to say the
embarrassing idea you learn to throw out
the thing that everybody looks kind of
quizzically at when you first say it and
you reward yourself for that behavior
you will lower that fear of failure and
that that fear there in a specific
context will then help you lower your
fear in a more general context I think
you want to practice you know you want
to you know be the change you want to
see in the world you want to model that
type of fearless behavior for yourself
for your friends for others because when
when people reflect back to you wow that
was a really crazy idea or wow you
really seem to be you know on today what
they're really doing is just saying that
you look like a different person you're
behaving a different way so you'll know
that your fear of failure is is
under control or dropping in a general
sense when you're able to behave in very
specific situations a brainstorm a group
meeting even in a meeting where people
have to come up with a you know analyze
a hard decision and you're the one
saying let's reframe this and look at it
differently you'll you'll know that
that's all of those practices are very
specific ways overcome wreck I'm coming
a general sense of of you know fear of
failure let's see is to do is it true
that the physically handicapped think
more creatively I don't know I met and
so that I've ever heard that before I
think what happens to for instance
people who are born blind or who feel
blind early in life remap the visual
portions of the brain to other senses
because it's just not necessary for the
visual sense and about fifty sixty
percent of our brain is processing
visual information all the time and so
you hear stories of folks who who are
blind who have acute sense of hearing
acute sense of smell acute sense of
touch I think they've just remapped the
processing that would have been taken up
by um by sight but I don't know that
there's any studies about other physical
handicaps or physical handicaps in
general creating more creativity I think
the folks that I know I have a good
friend of mine who's in a wheelchair and
he's just highly creative about how he
gets around the world but that's more
from necessity he's also one of the best
dancers I've ever met and you know he's
working with a different set of tools
but he's figuring out how to make it
work so I think it may be that you know
there's some stories around that but I
don't know that we have any evidence for
studies if anyone knows anything about
that that's been in the literature I'd
love to know